when the mob stormed the US capital on
January 6 2021 the government insisted
Joe bigs was a leader and an instigator
after a four-month trial the former Army
veteran was convicted of seditious
conspiracy he's now been given the
second longest sentence of any January 6
rioter 17 years the judge essentially
accepting the prosecution's argument
that bigs committed an act of terrorism
seeking to influence the government
through threats and acts of force the
tip of this spear for the mob was how
they characterized him also convicted
Zachary rail he was in the first wave of
riers to breach the capital spraying one
police officer in the face with an
irritant identified by the prosecution
is performing a key logistical role
intent on using violence to lead to a
civil war he was jailed for 15 years
afterwards the men's lawyers said both
had been influenced by the lies of
Donald Trump as judge Kelly noted in the
real
sentencing um it's a mitigating Factor
but not a justifying or excusing factor
but you know if your president tells you
your country's been stolen the country
that people fought and died for people
are trying to take your vote from you
how are you supposed to react to
that and these people reacted violently
and to their detriment the longest deel
term handed out to anyone involved in
what happened in Capitol Hill Remains
the one to the leader of the right-wing
self-styled militia the oathkeepers
Stuart rhods was jailed for 18 years
both bigs and rail were close allies of
The Proud boys chairman Enrique Taro he
has been convicted and will be sentenced
on Tuesday this can never happen again
and people who behaved in this way who
uh who tried to have a riot at the
capital and actually stop uh the
peaceful transfer of power that has
never happened in the United States
before and that deserves a very serious
penalty
Donald Trump will go on trial in the
same court building in March next year
on charges linked with his efforts to
overturn the result of the 2020
presidential election Alan Fischer Al
jazer
Washington make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer